I'm always amazed and I was when I just
saw the big sick that this thing that
you're able to do and I've I've met you
on several occasions before and I'm
always stunned because I'm used to
seeing you in film and you're a such a
powerful presence and when I say
powerful you can just take over and be
explosive and then when I need you
you're not a very big person and I'm
wondering how do you how do you do that
how do you channel where's that
intensity coming well let me see you
know it's a mystery it's funny because
if I if I only knew you from your work
in film I would think that someone needs
to go up to Holly Hunter and say you
gotta lighten up you got a leg because
you channel so much intensity are you
like that in real life well I mean I I
think you know like after years you know
on the couch but you know therapy with
therapy sessions I you know I have to
learn to tone it down in my real life so
that you know I you know sometimes I
think it I might be a little hard to
take
yeah I listen I'm gonna so that you
don't feel like you're going out on a
limb I'm gonna join you on that limb
believe it or not and Andy will back me
up on this I can be a little hard to
take sometimes don't laugh at that
ya know I get I get the you and me both
I mean so sometimes it's like blank
Holly yeah that you know that then it is
easier you know to absorb
oh so you're playing as you don't blink
people tell me stop hitting him here's
my question can you watch a performance
that you're giving when you watch
yourself and it's a performance that
everybody else loves are you able to
watch it and enjoy it or do you get too
self-conscious when you're looking at
yourself on screen well I think that you
know I'm a little bit of an extremist um
in that if I like my work I like my work
but I I don't love it but I can like it
right but if I hate it I really hate it
you know I
what I want to abolish it I don't you
know I want it to be I want it to be you
know I want it to be a nice droid you
wanted to be do you want it to be
removed from the public record and never
seen again
remove the private record - I mean it's
just like may it never exist right and
you need more therapy by the way because
the way probably the way you're going on
and on about it to not exist
I mean memories have to be removed you
know like it's like my therapy is like
generally sitting up but maybe it should
be lying down right I got creeped out I
tried the line down therapy analysis I
tried analysis once and the person sits
behind you and they don't say anything
for the whole session and I just get mad
like these are good jokes no one's
laughing
no I should be doing you know I totally
I totally know I I tried I tried that
and it did not work for me
yeah so I sit with someone and we go
back and forth but I would like to try I
would like to try analysis I think it
could be really interesting but how do
you know that they're good you don't
they don't say anything that's the whole
scam they don't say anything and at the
end I'm sorry I know I'm gonna get you
no emails from analysts but when they
sit behind you they don't say anything
at the end you go like what are you
thinking there wouldn't you think wait
now take the check
but wait don't they wait till a certain
point you got it you got a they got a
you load them up with everything you
know and then they tell you I never got
there I went and went and went and went
and went and went and then finally I
said I'm outta here and they went you're
really sick you need it stop
you